PICTURE OF THE KRUCHTTION.
THIS INDICTMENT IS ONLY A
PREVIEW OF COMING ATTRACTIONS.
DENT, AND GREGG JARRETT.
WE REPORTED LAST WEEK, THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT OPENED UP,
IT'S NOW BEEN GOING ON FOR
MONTHS, AN INVESTIGATION INTO
URANIUM ONE, IS THIS THE FIRST
OF MANY CARDS TO FALL?
>> YES, PROBABLY IS.
YOU KNOW, YOUR OPENING MONOLOGUE
ABOUT WEISSMANN IS ON POINT, HE
EXCHANGED INFORMATION ABOUT
MANAFORT, AND THEN JOINED THE
INVESTIGATION INTO MANAFORT,
HE'S VIOLATING D.O.J. RULES.
>> Sean: WHAT WOULD YOU DO IF
FILE A MOTION TO DISMISS WHICH
WOULD TRIGGER THE JUDGE TO ORDER
WEISSMANN TO REPORT.
>> Sean: IMMEDIATELY?
>> IMMEDIATELY.
>> Sean: WOULD ANY JUDGE ACCEPT
CONFLICT OF INTEREST.
AND LIST MANAFORT AND OTHERS
LIKE ROD ROSENSTEIN AS WITH ITS
IN THE CASE.
>> 30 TO 60 DAYS.
AND IF THEY ARE DESIGNATED TO BE
>> Sean: HAVE TO BE.
>> THEY WOULD ABSOLUTELY HAVE TO
BE.
>> Sean: IS THIS CORRUPT AS I
THINK?
>> IT IS CORRUPT.
>> Sean: SEBASTIAN GORKA, YOUR
TAKE ON THIS, A LOT OF MOVING
PARTS.
>> LOOK, GREGG OUTLINED IT
EXACTLY.
I'D LIKE TO PUT IT UP A BIT TO
THE STRATEGIC LEVEL.
I KNOW YOU HAVE MARK COMING ON,
MARK LEVIN, THE GREAT ONE.
>> Sean: THANK YOU.
>> I DON'T WANT TO STEAL HIS
THUNDER.
BUT MARK LEVIN NAILED ON IT THE
RADIO TODAY.
HE TALKS ABOUT THIS AS A
DOMESTIC SURVEILLANCE SCANDAL.
THAT'S WHAT IT IS.
AMERICA DOESN'T HAVE A SECRET
POLICE, IT DOESN'T HAVE AN
INTERNAL POLICE FORCE THAT SPIES
ON ITS OWN CITIZENS FOR
POLITICAL REASONS.
REASONS.
SPLEES IT DIDN'T UNTIL.
THE YOU BE CLASSIFIED PRESS --
UNCLASSIFIED PRESS ABOUT RUSSIAN
DISINFORMATION MATERIAL BEING
PAID FOR BY THE FBI AND BEING
USED TO GET FISA WARRANTS TO SPY
ON U.S. NATIONALS WHO ARE PART
OF A POLITICAL CAMPAIGN.
>> Sean: AND OPPOSITION PARTY
CANDIDATES, THEN SPY ON THE
QUESTION.
IF WE KNOW WIKILEAKS AND JULIAN
ASANG, AND I'VE INTERVIEWED HIM
FIVE TIMES, IF WE KNOW HE'S THE
E-MAILS AND SUCH, WHY HASN'T
MUELLER CONTACTED HIM?
WOULDN'T HE BE THE ONE GUY THAT
THEY WANT TO HURT TRUMP NOT HELP
TRUMP.
THEY'RE NOT SEARCHING FOR
EVIDENCE.
>> Shannon: THEY DON'T WANT THE
TRUTH.
>> NO, THEY WOULD TREFER TO
SUBVERT THE TRUTH.
>> Sean: I FEEL LIKE JACK
NICHOLSON, "YOU CAN'T HANDLE THE
TRUTH."
SEBASTIAN, LAST WORD.
>> THERE ARE A HANDFUL OF LARGE
POLITICAL SCANDALS IN AMERICAN
HISTORY.
JFK'S ASSASSINATION, THEN
WATERGATE, THEN WE HAVE THE
PENTAGON PAPERS.
I THINK THIS SCANDAL WILL TURN
OUT TO BE ONE OF THE BIGGEST
POLITICAL SCANDALS IN THE
HISTORY OF THE UNITED STATES.
WON'T TELL YOU WHO.
SAID THIS MAKES WATERGATE, IN
TERMS OF FISA SURVEILLANCE
ABUSES ALONE, LOOK LIKE
KINDERGARTEN.
>> I AGREE.
THIS WILL BE UP THERE WITH THE
ASSASSINATION OF JFK, THIS IS
HOW BIG, THE POLITICAL TARGETING
OF YOUR ENEMIES USING THE
INTELLIGENCE.
>> Sean: THEY DID IT TO WIN AN
ELECTION AND OVERTURN A DULY
ELECTED PRESIDENT.
YOU AGREE?
>> I AGREE.
IT'S UNDERMINING ELECTORAL
DEMOCRACY AND BLATANTLY
SUBVERTING JUSTICE.